digamos que tengo una línea que pasa por
el origen y para eso estamos pintando
nuestros ejes ok vamos a aplicarlos un
poco mas derechitos
aquí tengo mis 12 ejes y aquí esto lo
estoy dibujando en r2 aunque por
supuesto esta idea se puede extender
hasta rn y donde la gente puede ser tan
grande como tú quieras en realidad
puedes pensar en r 10 r 25.000 r un
millón 300 qué sé yo ok entonces vamos a
dibujar una línea que pase por el origen
insisto aquí a lo mejor estamos
dibujando lo en r2 pero esta idea la
podemos extender a cualquier rn tan
grande como quieras y tenemos ya esta
línea entonces esta línea digamos si
definimos un vector b
aquí está nuestro vector ve esta línea
estará definida como todos los múltiplos
de este vector de verdad se estira si
multiplicamos por números más grandes
que 1 vamos a estirando el vector en
esta dirección si son más chicos que 1
lo vamos encogiendo hasta llegar al 0 y
si son negativos pues entonces iremos en
dirección contraria entonces nuestra
recta l es el conjunto de todos los
múltiplos los múltiplos de nuestro
vector b donde los múltiplos estamos
pensando en que todos los de esa recta
se pueden escribir como un múltiplo real
de nuestro vector b ok entonces lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es ahondar en
la idea de lo que son las proyecciones o
más que ahondar quiero introducir la
idea de lo que es una proyección de un
vector x sobre una línea ok eso es lo
que quiero lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo y vamos a dibujar eso es decir qué
pasa si tenemos aquí
por equis
pintando todas estas ideas aquí tengo mi
vector x y entonces la idea más más pues
digamos la más sencilla que yo conozco
para para ir definiendo o dando la idea
de lo que es una proyección es suponer
que hay digamos rayos de luz que están
que están siendo emitidos en dirección
ortogonal a esta línea entonces vamos a
pensar que el vector x su proyección es
la sombra que genera es la sombra que
genera con esta línea l aunque entonces
sí si se está emitiendo la luz de forma
ortogonal entonces estamos pensando que
hasta este punto hasta este punto de
aquí
este vector el be pero además lo
estiramos más todo esto es la proyección
sobre l de nuestro vector x entonces
todo esto de aquí es la proyección sobre
l de nuestro vector x es decir lo
estamos pensando como la sombra que
dejaría si emitimos luz de forma
ortogonal a esta línea l ok entonces
vamos a pensarlo así como que la
proyección es la la sombra la sombra
en algún sentido de x sobre l sobre l y
estamos pensando las sombras y los rayos
de luz son ortogonales a la línea ok
entonces creo que creo que la sombra de
hecho pensándolo como una sombra es más
intuitivo de por qué se le llama esta
proyección también podríamos pensarlo en
que es el vector digamos que se
encuentra sobre esta línea el que
tenemos que sumarle a un vector
ortogonal para obtener nuestro vector x
por ejemplo si yo tuviera un vector más
chico pues éste no sería la proyección
verdad entonces realmente necesitamos
extender este vector b que es el que
genera la línea tanto o lo suficiente
como para que con este vector ortogonal
a la línea podamos generar a nuestro
vector x podemos verlo en ambos sentidos
para mí es mucho más fácil pensarlo como
como la sombra verdad
lo que quiero decir con esto es
simplemente una idea intuitiva porque no
podemos hacer matemáticas con esta
definición verdad queremos al menos
calcular o queremos saber cómo podemos
encontrar de forma pues digamos ya con
con vectores reales con operaciones con
cuentas como podemos encontrar esta
proyección ok entonces vamos a vamos a
seguir por ejemplo vamos a dar sólo son
un último ejemplo de cómo se verían
estas proyecciones para que quede muy
claro por ejemplo si si tuviéramos un
vector que estuviera por aquí pues
entonces la proyección sería este vector
de aquí de este vector de aquí abajo ok
pero bueno vamos a ir definiendo de
forma más precisa todo esto porque si
nosotros queremos definir la proyección
sobre el de nuestro vector x
y entonces nuevamente este es el vector
proyección es nuestra sombra y este es x
entonces como dijimos hace unos momentos
necesitamos que este vector forme un
ángulo de 90 grados con la línea en este
vector de aquí de gemelo lo marco mejor
este vector de aquí este vector de aquí
debe formar un ángulo de 90 grados con
la línea pero quién es este vector es un
vector que al sumarle la proyección nos
da x entonces es x menos la proyección
sobre el de x verdad si a este vector le
sumamos la proyección pues en efecto nos
da x entonces lo que vamos a tener aquí
es que este vector rosa que pinte x
menos la proyección debe ser ortogonal a
toda la línea l como podemos describir
eso entonces la proyección dicho en
palabras es algún vector que no sabemos
aún cuál es algún vector
en nuestra recta l dónde
dónde o tal que x menos la proyección
sobre l de nuestro vector x sea
ortogonal es ortogonal
ortogonal a nuestra recta el ok y otra
vez esto es es la idea de la proyección
está dicho en palabras es un poco más
preciso que la que las sombras de x
sobre l sin embargo no podemos aún
calcular nada verdad esto todavía está
dicho en palabras entonces como lo
calculamos fíjense que como estamos
tomándonos algún vector en l eso quiere
decir que debe ser un múltiplo de b pues
así está definido l verdad el conjunto
de todos los múltiplos de b así que en
particular esta proyección debe ser
igual a un c por b para para alguno
algún se no sabemos aún cuál algún cmr
entonces todo el problema recae en ver
cómo calcular esta ce y para hacer eso
no tenemos que x menos la proyección es
ortogonal a él es decir si yo hago el
producto punto con cualquier sector que
se encuentre en nuestra línea l nos debe
dar 0 entonces x menos se por b punto
cualquier vector que se encuentra en l
en particular pues puede ser el mismo
vector b
punto d es igual a 0 es igual a 0 y aquí
vamos a utilizar nuestras propiedades
del producto punto para poder
simplificar esto y determinar un valor
para hacer todo esto estamos pensando es
la proyección y como el producto punto
es distributivo entonces vamos a tener
aquí x punto de menos
con un tope que de hecho sé por bebé lo
podemos asociar de esta forma verdad
déjenme déjenme quitar esto en realidad
podemos sacar a la cee del producto
punto y ponerlo de esta forma que
multiplica esto y esto nos debe dar 0
ahora bien si nosotros sumamos o pasamos
este término del lado derecho sumando
tenemos x punto b es igual hace por de
punto b y esto ya queda clarísimo
exactamente de cómo entonces puedo
encontrar hacer porque si esto lo paso
dividiendo tendríamos que ser es igual a
x punto b sobre b punto b muy bien
entonces ya tenemos un valor exacto para
encontrar nuestro nuestro c que es el
múltiplo o el escalar por el cual tengo
que multiplicar a b para obtener la
proyección entonces sólo para redondear
la proyección sobre l de nuestro vector
x
es igual a un múltiplo ce por nuestro
vector b por nuestro vector b sin
embargo ya sabemos quién es de verdad
porque se es x punto b sobre de punto b
que multiplica a nuestro vector b ok
entonces aquí por ejemplo pues en el
dibujo podríamos pensarlo como que pues
más o menos se ve que esta constante c
que nos da de calcular esto debe ser 2
verdad más o menos por aquí anda ve más
o menos es como como como el doble
verdad estamos re escalando el vector b
para obtener la proyección ok y todo
esto como ya les había comentado puede
extenderse en general a rn verdad para
en es incluso mucho muy muy muy grandes
entonces vamos a hacer un ejemplo para
que veas que no es tan abstracto el
concepto vamos a definir una línea l
digamos que sea el conjunto de todos los
múltiplos del vector
vamos a decir que el vector 21 que son
todos los múltiplos es la recta que
vamos a hacer y vamos a hacer un dibujo
para que quede muy claro
aquí tengo mi eje x
aquí tendré
este es el eje x este de aquí es el eje
y este es el eje x el eje i y necesito
graficar el vector 21 entonces si yo
tengo aquí el 1
aquí el 2 y luego aquí tengo el 1
entonces tengo aquí nuestro vector 2 1
el vector
hacerlo un poquito mejor aquí está el
vector 21 y como estamos pintando toda
la línea pues en sí es todos todos los
múltiplos de este vector verdad lo
podremos extender en ambas direcciones
muy bien esa es la línea y vamos a
considerarnos otro vector digamos el x
igual a 2 3 al 2 3
23 entonces aquí está 2 1 2 3
este vector
es mi vector x y queremos encontrar
nuestra proyección corto y la proyección
que genere aquí un vector que sea
ortogonal a la línea verdad más o menos
como está en este dibujo entonces
podemos calcular fácilmente esto con la
formulita que ya tenemos porque la
proyección sobre nuestra línea l del
vector x es igual al 23 23 verdad es el
vector x 23 punto el vector que genera
la línea que es el 21 sobre 21
punto
21 y esto es sólo la constante ce aún
falta multiplicar por nuestro vector que
genera la línea que es el 21 entonces
esa constante multiplica al vector 21 y
esto quienes vamos a ver si hacemos el
producto punto de estos dos es 2 por 2
es 43 por uno es 3 43 son 7 y aquí abajo
nos queda dos por dos es cuatro más uno
por uno que es uno entonces cuatro más
uno son cinco que multiplica a nuestro
vector 21 y que pues al menos ya aquí
tenemos la respuesta pero bueno podemos
vernos un poquito más explícitos y
multiplicar cada uno de éstos por siete
quintos y entonces dos por siete quintos
son 14 quintos y 7 quintos por uno son
siete quintos
y ahí lo tienen y que pues 14 quintos
son 2 por 5 son 10 y sobran 4
y 40 en 35 son hoy aquí es 2.8 y luego 7
en 35 pues es a 1
1 punto haberes 1 por 5 son 5 sobran 2
bajamos un 0 5 por 4 20 entonces es 1.4
entonces esto es para que podamos más o
menos dibujarlo y aquí tenemos que es 1
digamos y por aquí en el 3 se ve más o
menos que aquí es el 2.8 y de altura es
el 1.4 más o menos por aquí está la
mitad más o menos entonces si queda muy
bien con el dibujo y con toda la idea
intuitiva que teníamos detrás entonces
coincide perfectamente con nuestra idea
de la proyección como una sombra ahora
ya sabes calcular proyecciones en el
próximo vídeo voy a mostrarte cómo sé
cómo se puede dar una representación
matricial de las proyecciones que
entonces esencialmente nos dice que son
transformaciones lineales